vocês sabiam que 95% do nosso cérebro
acontece no nosso cérebro olímpico 95%
dos nossos pensamentos e nossas crenças
dos nossos valores nossas tomada de
decisão do nosso imaginário ficam nesse
teu cérebro olímpico
e ela também desse processo os modelos
mentais
então agora vou falar com o cérebro
livro de vocês
a gente vive hoje no mundo a terceira
revolução é a chamada revolução digital
revolução tecnológica
essa revolução está trazendo muitos
avanços muitas mudanças nas nossas vidas
a maneira como a gente vive como a gente
se relaciona com a gente trabalha como
agente se alimenta e muitos avanços
positivos estão acontecendo no mundo
como os celulares com reconhecimento
facial drones carros automáticos enfim é
coisas que a gente jamais imaginou fora
da ficção científica então aconteceu nas
nossas vidas
mas apesar de todos os avanços da
humanidade da vivi grandes problemas
problemas complexos que estão aí né de
ordem social ambiental e educacional etc
e como lidar com esses problemas né
gente adotar a lógica cartesiana linear
que é a lógica do modelo industrial no
século passado
ela não dá conta mas de desse mundo de
hoje é porque ela é linear no nosso
mundo não é mais linear
ela está ultrapassada como modelo mental
então seria o ideal para nós como modelo
mental do século 21
pergunto pra vocês o modelo mental do
século 21 na minha visão é o modelo do
design
então gente que é reserva está se
perguntando agora que modelo mental do
design que isso é assim um modelo mental
do design e é o seguinte o design ele
não é só uma profissão não é só uma
formação não é só uma prática
o design é uma forma de a gente chegar
um deles é a forma como eu vejo quando
decidi fazer design
eu não sabia muito bem o que era
o design achava que era uma coisa que
projetava o futuro a gente criar coisas
novas mas não sabe exatamente onde
aquilo ia me levar e eu vim de uma
família que é muito criativo é muito
curiosa é a minha mãe é uma grande
lutadora e ela fazia muitos uns deitados
nos desenhos livros me ligava muito e
quando a gente era pequena fazia muitas
coisas manuais e meu pai engenheiro
naval muito curioso também e eu tinha
uma rota era pintora que me ensinou as
cores as formas os volumes e tenho um
avô do outro lado que era dentista
mas não era só um dentista ele é também
um inventor
ele criava jogos pra gente fez lá eu e
minhas irmãs iam jogos incríveis super
criativo sobre referente diferentes e
originais e hoje eu vejo que tudo isso
me inspirou porque na verdade todos eles
estavam criando idéias estavam
projetando coisas que eu só entende isso
agora né
e essa é a minha vida então eu fui fazer
design com 16 anos porque com 15 anos a
minha madrinha me levou pra conhecer uma
agência de publicidade onde ela
trabalhava e quando eu entrei no estúdio
existe um estúdio prancheta que hoje em
dia não existe mais
quando entrei naquele estúdio falei
nossa eu quero trabalhar com isso eu
quero ser igual a essas pessoas aqui
quero desenhar quero inventar criar e
hoje eu vejo eu entendo aquilo como
aquilo representava pra mim um campus
uma tela vazia perante o mundo e eu acho
que isso que é o design
e aí como é que a gente traz esse modelo
mental para hoje
como é que a gente usa ou esse modelo
mental do design no nosso mundo resolver
problemas complexos
eu trouxe pra vocês três ingredientes
que eu acho que são fundamentais nesse
pensamento
o primeiro deles é questionar nós
designers somos somos muito inquietos
a gente está sempre se perguntando
porque isso tem que ser dessa forma
porque não pode ser de outra forma
sexo não pode ser diferente a gente tá
sempre questionando a gente está sempre
desconstruindo a realidade e sempre
querendo que seja melhor se retirando
uma versão melhor daquilo isso é a nossa
cabeça nós somos assim
é uma um bichinho rebelde que moravam da
gente que está sempre querendo melhorar
as coisas não é essa atitude
questionadora que vem acompanhada de uma
atitude uma postura investigativa também
de querer entender as coisas é muito
importante no processo
nesse modelo mental de design e aí eu
trago um exemplo aqui pra vocês que de
um projeto com a participar e muito
recentemente na verdade na semana
passada
conheci uma pessoa no rio este ano em
março que é uma pessoa que trabalha com
cultura e com mobilizações sociais que a
daniel e ela me convidou pra pra essa
oficina numa cidade do litoral
catarinense onde a idéia é o seguinte as
pessoas existe uma um problema de
talento de saneamento básico na cidade e
as pessoas estavam inconformados com
aquela solução em vias de ser
implementado as pessoas da cidade e aí
ela organizou a dani organizou uma
oficina e eu fui conduzir esse processo
também além do design e foi incrível
nessa oficina tinham engenheiros
ambientais engenheiros florestais
florestais agrônomos e arquitetos
paisagistas antropólogos biólogos
geólogos geógrafos muitas pessoas
competentes e através do processo de
design
eles chegaram as soluções incríveis
perfeitamente viáveis problema de
saneamento básico eles vão levar isso à
frente agora eu espero que sejam
implementadas as idéias deles traziam
recursos muito modernos como zona de
raízes em uma série de recursos
existentes hoje que são favoráveis à
natureza e ao meio ambiente
ao contrário da solução que está em vias
de ser implementado então esse exemplo
traz essa idéia de questionar por que
através desse olhar profissional dessas
pessoas que se mobilizaram uma sociedade
civil é uma possibilidade grande ser
resolvida essa questão do saneamento
através do seu olhar colecionador o
segundo ingrediente a imaginação ea
imaginação ela é o motor da criatividade
na verdade ela mora dentro da gente ea
gente só usa ela quando a gente era
criança
depois a gente esquece que a gente entra
em uma vida de trabalho e de modelo
quase 1
o trial é que é o vigente hoje nas
empresas nas escolas
a gente esquece ser criativo a gente
esquece a gente sabe criar e sabe tem
ideias ea criatividade que faz a gente
não dá pra frente
faz a gente sair do dondi a gente está e
dá um passo à frente outro lado para
criar coisas diferentes para inovar é um
motor de inovação e como a criatividade
pode ajudar nos projetos né
na resolução de problemas e aí eu trouxe
o exemplo que eu gosto muito é o
seguinte eu tava dando um curso no rio
alguns anos atrás e um curso de design
já entendem que na verdade e uma pessoa
geral participam pessoas que são da área
ou de áreas semelhantes mas se um médico
lá fazendo discurso ele foi cantado e
até fez um cria uma idéia muito
interessante do curso e alguns meses
depois ele me ligou na causa
ele trabalhava no hospital é um rio de
janeiro no hospital estadual e ele falou
que faria se não quer fazer um projeto
no hospital pra gente pensar um problema
muito grave usar o design para isso
lógico como fazer ea gente montou uma
equipe de voluntários que não estão aqui
na foz fizemos um projeto pra eles
focado nesse problema da higienização
das mãos no cpi era um problema bem
específico mas que por incrível que
pareça ainda a causa de muitos e muitas
mortes muitas infecções muitos problemas
hospitalares um problema simples mas
muito muito abrangente na verdade
e aí a gente fez uma oficina também com
pessoas do hospital a gente fez na
verdade um projeto com uma imersão
conversando com os começamos com vários
setores do hospital desde da parte de
manutenção até áreas técnicas com os
médicos e juntamos todos eles para
pensar soluções médico chefe de seção
enfermeiros chefe de enfermagem técnico
de raio x em todos os níveis do hospital
estavam ali juntos e eles pensaram
soluções incrível isso é que eu jamais
imaginei por exemplo é um dos grupos
criam uma solução que era um anjo
hospitalar a uma pessoa que ficaria
responsável por tomar conta dessa
lavagem das mãos
tentaremos ser que ele tenha um papel um
pouco de anjo é outro grupo criou uma
idéia um simples que era um gel que
ficava na porta do ct i ea porta sós
abrir se a pessoa colocar se ele passa
as mãos com gel
outra idéia envolve a identificação
enfim uma série de idéias incríveis para
um problema complexo e criadas por
especialistas e íntimos
multidisciplinares e quando eu fui fazer
design
eu tinha 16 anos quando entrei na
faculdade e os primeiros 20 anos da
minha profissão eu trabalhei vários
países do mundo
muitas religiões muitas pessoas muitas
culturas conheci muita gente diferente
só que depois desses 20 anos eu falei eu
preciso mas eu preciso fazer o design
das pessoas e hoje eu trabalho com esse
processo de facilitação de criação
criação para ajudar as pessoas a
pensarem como designers e eu adoro fazer
isso é isso que eu faço hoje nos nas
oficinas nos cursos nas organizações as
instituições em casa com meus filhos eu
trago isso pra tudo
eu acredito nisso muito e é isso que eu
faço hoje trabalho com times
multidisciplinares para resolver
problemas de várias ordens
na verdade eu ajudo eles resolverem
trazendo as ferramentas de design ea
último último ingrediente à
experimentação porque no design é muito
importante experimentar a gente cria uma
idéia a gente olha sempre para quem vai
usar a gente faça toda essa pesquisa a
gente cria idéias ea gente leva elas
ateste a gente experimenta porque a
gente acredita que testando a gente
aprende e através do erro que a gente
evoluir nos cria novas versões aquilo
que a gente criou então o erro ele é
bem-vindo fracasso é bem vindo e isso é
muito raro no nosso mundo de hoje porque
as empresas enfim as instituições as
escolas a gente não aceita muito erro né
você tira uma nota baixa você leva logo
né de casado na escola não se você é seu
chefe
enfim dá uma bronca que pode ser
demitido ele não é bem visto
mas eu acho que por um pra gente viver
no mundo de hoje
o erro ele ele faz parte do faz parte do
processo
essa aqui é o desenho que eu fiz para
ilustrar essa experimentação
não é que pensar abertas pensar várias
possibilidades né
vários níveis e aí entrou esse é o
último exemplo é saiu de dentro de um
curso que eu coordenei lá no rio onde a
gente estava trabalhando para uma ong
que trabalha com ocupação de espaços
públicos no rio e um dos grupos criou
uma ideia é não foi uma praça do rio que
é conversando com as pessoas e eles
entenderam que as pessoas precisariam de
um dos freqüentadores de uma praça e uma
determinada praça
eles entenderam que seria interessante
aplicar algumas idéias com uma horta
urbana entre outras idéias e essa idéia
foi implementada essa foto do jornal
essas crianças estão plantando de fato
nessa ordem foi criada por um grupo
multidisciplinar no curso também então é
eu acredito que o design possa trazer
essa esse modelo mental que mora dentro
do nosso cérebro olímpico e que ele seja
muito importante fundamental como um
potencial motor transformador o nosso
mundo de hoje que está contando os
problemas ea gente tem isso na mão como
ferramenta então o design também é como
se fosse uma lente e eu acredito que
todos nós possamos olhar através dessa
lente e é isso que eu queria trazer para
vocês e hoje no mundo existem muitas
iniciativas já comece que não sei pra
vocês e outras em vários lugares do
mundo onde se usa essa abordagem e
avanços muito grandes no campo humano e
da inovação
então eu desejo que vocês experimentem e
conheço essas formas de olhar o mundo
boa viagem obrigado